and finally new rules someone has to
explain to me why Republicans believe
that not working and getting free money
you know like the takers is the worst
most corrupting thing that could ever
happen to a person except if you're rich
the very first thing our new Republican
Congress tried to do is get rid of any
tax on inherited wealth which they call
the death tax although really what
better time is there to pay attacks than
when you're dead yeah we used to
understand that and the estate tax used
to be pretty high but then President
George W Bush came along and worked
tirelessly to make sure that rich idle
trust fund brats got every penny that
was coming to them I wonder where he got
the idea to reward dumbasses who leach
off their dad's success
well
it is true if there's one thing that
really chaps the conservative ass it's
the idea of people getting money for
nothing and tricks for free Paul Ryan
says we have a culture of men not
working generations of men not even
thinking about working or learning the
value in the culture of work yes so true
like for example this douche bag this is
the youngest heir to the Hilton Hotel
fortune Paris Hilton's brother Conrad
Hughes [ __ ] Hilton who who last year
was on a flight from London when he get
this tried to smoke pot and cigarettes
up to 20 times in the bathroom disabled
the smoke detector physically fought
with the flight crew and then told them
I could get you all fired in five
minutes I know your boss and when told
he was upsetting the other passengers
said I will own [ __ ] anyone on this
flight they are [ __ ] peasants and
when the crew finally had to physically
restrain him he said my father will pay
this out he's done it before kind of
makes you think why can't we book this
kid on a Malaysian airline
and before you say but bill every kid
who inherits money doesn't become an
entitled jerk let me give you two names
Donald Trump who once said what I find
so morally offensive about welfare
dependency is it robs people of the
jed's to improve again so true
Republicans are right not having to work
and getting free money does mess people
up that's why they love to talk about
work the virtue of work the right to
work work fair the dignity that comes
with work in fact there's only one thing
conservatives believe in more than work
and that's the god-given right of rich
people to leave all their money to their
kids so they never have to work a day in
their lives
I mean think about it Republicans are on
board with taxing people's income their
investments property food gas booze
cigarettes everything you buy even your
retirement those are all ok but the one
thing that must remain tax free is when
money falls from the sky and lands in
the lap of [ __ ] Hilton but you know
if the tough love of cutting off free
money for the poor is the right thing to
do how can we stand by and do any less
for the Conrad Hilton's of the world
they've never known the dignity of work
either shouldn't we be helping them by
taxing inheritance at 100%
what about poor Kylie Jenner when she
turned 16 she got a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollar Mercedes and
crashed it into some other motorists who
didn't understand she was in a hurry and
here she is this week a month after her
father's deadly accident texting while
driving there's got to be some way to
get her off the road and into a
minimum-wage job at Hot Dog on a Stick
and then there's little Ethan couch he's
the Texas teenager who killed four
pedestrians while driving drunk and pled
I'm not kidding about this a condition
called affluenza yes affluenza which
basically says he didn't know boundaries
because his rich parents didn't give him
any and it worked
he got off so ask your doctor if being
rich is right for you